[Music]
i wasn't looking i just
stood up and banged my head on the
flange
what are you doing here so late it has
to be ready for inspection
before the launch tomorrow i guess i'm
gonna do it for you i'm not someone
someone gets
so you think what i did was stupid
it's not for me to say don't give me
that
you have an opinion my opinion
is you want me to be scared of you and i
don't know why
you've seen us all up there on that
machine what have you noticed
that you're the slowest to react and you
take the longest to recover
and if you were to um
if you were to examine one of us and you
found something what would you do
i would make sure you understood that
anything you told me in confidence would
remain private
unless it jeopardized you or the project
why should we trust you do you trust
anyone
i trust myself that sounds lonely
says the girl working late on a friday
night
i'm sitting here aren't i am
i'm talking to you the way i'm talking
you can call it trust you can call it
whatever you want
[Music]
you